the world is looking to shift to
electric cars and reduce co2 emissions
in transport
to feed this new demand electric vehicle
battery technology is developing rapidly
but with many different solutions new
safety issues arise and for regulators
it can be hard to set the line between
innovation and safety
could we help them to access harmonized
testing data from different sources to
make better and faster regulatory
decisions
we developed new tests addressing
potential safety issues in modern
batteries to help shape regulation
worldwide
our team started by analyzing existing
laws and testing procedures across
countries so that we could address gaps
in regulation
because a vehicle battery catching fire
can be so destructive we're developing a
new test on thermal propagation based on
our research on the many ways such a
reaction could be triggered
once the complete process is validated
in experiments we can propose that it
becomes part of laws to make vehicles
safer
in 2018 our researchers work on
assessing the toxicity of battery
electrolytes resulted in a new global
legal requirement for electric vehicle
safety
this updated global regulation is
expected to include the new thermal
propagation test
with better harmonized test procedures
and global regulation
the jrc and its partners are
facilitating the development of safer
electric vehicles for a sustainable low
carbon world
[Music]